gobble-gobble with me and Mariah and
mainly with Mariah but I'll be there too
this Thanksgiving we're thankful for
Mariah Carey performing live in Honolulu
with Empire star Jesse small act the
actor opened up to ET backstage at the
iHeartRadio Music Festival in Las Vegas
on Saturday where he gushed over working
with Miss Mimi Mariah is just amazing
support that she showed me so far has
just been she absolutely did not have to
be as supportive as she is but she has
been so the first it was supposed to be
one night only that sold out in like a
couple of hours and they added a second
show that sold out so now we're going to
do three shows
not only is just a primetime fixture on
Empire he's also had some early mornings
guest hosting live with Kelly Ripa
Mariah who sing at your wedding as for
speculation he might sit next to Kelly
permanently Jessie tells et he just
doesn't have the time that honestly is
just so much fun and Kelly's become a
good friend since I first went on the
show like a year and a half ago so it's
just fun to play with her but this is
definitely not you know for me there's
there's no chance that I would ever be
able to do something like that guys just
you know Jamal Connick takes it all the
time